[Musique]
ouais
une des plus grandes tragédies de
l'histoire des états unis pour plus cet
homme à la présidence à dallas au texas
son état natal il est aux côtés de john
f kennedy comme vice président lyndon
johnson se trouve dans une limousine un
peu en arrière quand des coups de feu le
président d'adp
il est dans l'avion présidentiel avec la
veuve jackie kennedy y la juge ça use la
serre manque l'avion portant le cercueil
du président assassiné atterri à la base
andrews
c'est là que le président johnson
prononce son premier discours
discret moment méditer sur la nefac
discours bref au budget comme on
l'appelle par ses initiales voulait être
président en 1960 john kennedy gagne
l'investiture démocrate et choisit son
adversaire que vice président il en
avait besoin pour gagner des voix du sud
est exact budget et sénateurs avec déjà
une très longue carrière derrière lui
c'est un vieux routier du congrès il
sait comment manoeuvrer démocrates et
républicains cajoler menacé même c'est
le fameux traitement johnson et obtenir
ce qu'il veut un consensus sur ces
propositions
lyndon baines johnson est né à stonewall
au texas dans une ferme de descendants
de pionnier il fréquente l'école
publique et décide de devenir enseignant
il a été assez sensibilisés à la cause
la cause afro-américaine beaucoup parce
que les temps lui même issu d'un milieu
très modeste et se reconnaissaient dans
la pauvreté qui frappe et de manière
disproportionnée les afro américains
particulièrement à ceux des états unis
en 1931 il se lance en politique il
épouse claudia connu et aimé sous le nom
de lady bird
en 1937 il entre au congrès des états
unis comme représentant d'austin
capitale du texas il devient
vice-président 1960 mais la famille
kennedy
ces aristocrates de nouvelle angleterre
n'aime pas ce terme manière brusque
parfois grossières mais le président
john f kennedy s'efforce de le tenir
occupés et informer abidji remporte haut
la main un an plus tard l'élection
présidentielle lorsqu'il accède à la
présidence tout le monde pense qu'on va
avoir droit à un démocrate conservateur
du sud
mais c'est un peu la surprise qu'on a
c'est de voir finalement celui qui met
de l'avant des programmes politiques les
plus progressistes xxème siècle avec
cette société qui fait un imposant
programme de réformes
il déclare la guerre à la pauvreté de
vastes programmes sociaux sont mis en
place
medicare et medicaid pour la santé des
personnes âgées des pauvres le seuil de
pauvreté tombe de 23 à 12 %
il instaure la radiodiffusion publique
la protection de l'environnement et
poursuit l'oeuvre inachevée de kennedy
les droits civiques et le droit de vote
pour toutes les minorités
[Applaudissements]
malgré ces réformes audacieuses le
mandat de johnson est marquée par de
violentes émeutes raciales dans le
quartier ouest de los angeles notamment
et par des assassinats politiques celui
de martin luther king et celui de robert
kennedy le frère du président assassiné
qui l'avait gardé brièvement comme
secrétaire à la justice la politique
étrangère de johnson est un désastre
soutient des dictatures en amérique
latine et en haïti et surtout l'
escalade au vietnam ce qui était une
intervention de soutien au sud vietnam
devient une guerre ouverte qui s'étend
au laos et au cambodge
la guerre est extrêmement populaire et
elle fera oublier le reste du monde
adulte budget je pense que c'est un
président qui à tout le moins était
peut-être moins sous-estimé n'a pas le
charisme la stature historique peut
l'avoir kennedy même si la plupart des
changements progressifs la société
américaine ont été faits sous la
présidence de johnson
linden by johnson lui même déprimé
considère que sa présidence est un échec
il décide de ne pas se représenter
[Musique]